I don't know about all this soap opera
what I do know about is that the people
are completely Fed Up about this roller
coaster of chaos and incompetence that
they've been witnessing
they will get a chance in the near
future to be able to express themselves
and I'm quite sure that they will be
showing just how disgusted they are with
all of this it doesn't seem to matter
what leader they get it just continues
to be chaos
no he says it's a Witch Hunt to get him
out of parliament do you do you agree
with that is there is there a Witch Hunt
going on it does sometimes look like one
I think that Boris Johnson has brought
all this on himself but you know it's a
soap opera what the public want to know
about is who is going to look after
their interests who's going to be
actually interested in in in the cost of
living in looking after all hospitals in
making sure that we fight crime on our
streets that's what should be important
not all this nonsense not all this chaos
and not all this corruption does this
have any implications for Rishi cynic
I think the all it shows is that it
doesn't matter who is in charge
the chaos and the corruption continues
the soap opera continues that people
want to have someone who is going to
look after them and look after their
interests who's going to focus on the
cost of living is going to be fixing our
hospitals going to be fighting crime on
our streets uh what do you think of uh
Mr Johnson's resignation honors list
I think that
we're expecting
it is I think just fits in with the
chaos and the corruption that I've been
talking about it seems to me that we
need to move on and whenever I speak to
anybody they are desperate to see the
back of this lot they are desperate to
see a back of the chaos and the
corruption that this government have
brought us and they want to have one
that's going to look after them
and just finally what chances do labor
have in that by-election it's an
extremely conservative area that's an
understatement what do you think your
hopes are honestly
if you look at the polling the re sorry
if you look at the recent polling the
seat by seat polling we are not only in
second place we are really close so we
have a very good chance of beating the
conservatives in mid-beds and not least
because the public are fed up with
having a government that is ignoring
them and they are fed up with having
Nadine Doris who in turn has been
ignoring them but we are an alternative
and our priorities other people's
priorities which is fixing hospitals
which is fighting crime in our streets
and looking after people because of the
cost of living crisis